[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
just a man and his will to survive
[Music]
so many times it happens too
[Music]
your fast on the dreams of the past you
must fight
just to keep them alive
[Music]
is
[Music]
to oh
[Music]
is
what's the distance
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i'm tired
[Music]
oh
please please please
[Music]
please
[Music]
baby you did me wrong
[Music]
[Music]
please
[Music]
please
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
take my hand
i wanna be your
[Music]
i love you so much
[Music]
oh
[Music]
time after time
after my sentence
[Music]
but committed no crime
and bad mistakes
i've met a few
[Music]
[Music]
till the end
[Music]
[Music]
we are the champion
[Music]
i've
[Music]
i consider it a challenge
[Music]
my friends
[Music]
we are
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my friends
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me baby
[Music]
in the morning
[Music]
hey
[Music]
oh
[Music]
my
is
[Music]
always
[Music]
leader he
[Music]
uh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
up
[Music]
[Music]
still
ladies and gentlemen the 45th
president of the united states donald
j trump and i'm proud
and i won't forget the men who died
who gave
[Music]
god bless the usa
[Music]
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of texas
from sea to shining sea
from detroit down to houston
and new york to l.a
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's time we stand and say
[Music]
[Music]
the men who died who gave
[Music]
god bless the usa
[Music]
i know i'm free and
[Music]
next to you and defend her still today
because there ain't no doubt i love this
[Music]
land
oh what a crowd this is some crowd wow
this is a big crowd
well thank you very much this is a great
crowd we have a lot of great crowds
there's something happening you're going
to see that
on the third although the supreme court
would probably like to delay it for a
long time it looks like
but we're going to have a tremendous
victory it's going to be a victory like
none other it's the most important
election of our lives hello michigan
how are you doing michigan how are you
doing
it's cold but i feel very warm in this
group this is a great group
four days from now we are going to win
this state
and we are going on to win four more
great years in the white house
we're gonna have it we're gonna have it
unless there's something that we don't
see you know i'm watching these biden
rallies it's like
there's nobody of course he says that
they want to do it that way on purpose
you know the problem is nobody shows up
they were putting on the screen our
rally that's you you're all famous very
famous
and his rally there was nobody at least
he's doing a rally he got out of the
basement so that's true
with your support we will continue to
bring back your jobs cut your taxes cut
your regulations
support our great police
support our military defend our borders
protect
the second amendment which is under
siege
protect always religious liberty
and ensure more products are proudly
stamped
with the wonderful phrase you know what
it is made
in the usa that's happening board
thanks to our historic campaign to slash
red tape and mobilize industry
we will deliver a safe vaccine to the
american people
in just a number of weeks a couple of
weeks it's happening very fast
great companies the greatest companies
of their kind in the world
and we've got plenty of them there too
seniors will
be first we make seniors first right
thank you thank you very much
thank you they say will you be the first
one to take it you know it's a no-win
situation if i say yes they'll say he
demanded to be first if i say no
they'll say he had no courage now we're
going to take care of our seniors first
we're going to take care of our
doctors and front line workers everybody
but it's
really and by the way you know without
it we're still rounding the corner we
have it
but without it we're around the corner
and it will be available free we're
doing the vaccine free and the reason is
that this wasn't your fault this wasn't
anyone's work
this was china's fault
just remember it our vaccine will
eradicate the virus much more quickly
and in the pandemic quickly quickly
quickly
because we want to have our life
restored just to normal that's all we
want
that's all we want normal
we just want normal bring us back seven
months that's what we want right
and that's what the whole world wants
look what's happening in europe it's
terrible
it's terrible what china has done to
this world
and just remember it just remember it
and next year will be the greatest
economic year in the history of our
country you see what's happening
33.1 nobody can blame they can't believe
it
they don't like talking about it
you know they don't like talking about
it do you have a new thing going
it's called
thank you
thank you
you hear that ben carson you hear that
ben
[Music]
i'll tell you nobody's ever heard that
before politically maybe for ben carson
i don't know
i love ben carson thank you ben
candy thank you thank you candy
joe biden is promising a long dark
painful winter did you see him at the
debate
did anybody see the debate by any chance
no he said the long dark winter oh
that's great that's wonderful
that's just what our country needs is a
long dark winter
and a leader that talks about it you
know
i didn't have the privilege of going to
my basement in the white house
i didn't have the privilege of going to
a beautiful room on the second or third
floor
and staying there for a year and a half
because i'm president of the united
states so i didn't have that
i had to do my job and i said you know i
could catch this thing and if i do i do
and i'm going to get better fast i
didn't know it's going to get better
that fair that was pretty good
i was like in and out and you know i had
a dose i wasn't feeling great but i got
better
and it used to be that say you have
lifetime
immunity right you're you're immune now
it's different because it's me they say
i'm good for four months okay
they brought it down from lifetime to
four months but that's okay i'll take it
but you know what you have to do your
job you have to get back
you have to open up your states right
you have to open up your states
not again we got to get our governor to
open up our state here don't we
you know oh don't worry on november 4th
they'll announce all these states all
these democrat-run states will be open
not me
not me see
they blame me every time that happens
every time i mention her name
crooked hillary's name joe biden's name
frankly
and where's hunter where's hunter
there's hunter right there he's out by
the truck
looking to make a couple of bucks hunter
hunter's thing
hunter's done very well for an
unemployed person right for years
for years unemployed and then he uh he
hit painter and his father became vice
president
and joe hit pay dirt too that's part of
the problem
i'm delivering the great american
comeback that's what we're doing
we built we built
the greatest economy in the history of
the world
best unemployment numbers best
everything we had 160 million people
employed we were never even close to
that number
and then one day we saved two million
lives we had to close it up how about
that decision we had
oh how horrible to have to make it we
understood the disease we learned the
disease we have to protect our seniors
especially if they have problems with
the heart or diabetes
we opened it up and now we're at a level
we're used to talking about the v
this is a super v this is the biggest
number
33.1 and the news doesn't want to talk
about it because it's positive
they only want to talk about negative
when it comes to us
but 33.1 the biggest number in our
country's history by like double but
it's more much more than double and
you'd have to go back to 1952
to get anywhere close but close your
north close is about a 17 17-point
spread
this election is a matter of economic
survival for michigan because joe biden
look at what they did during their eight
years and you know i said during the
debate
91 to 9 91 you know what that means it
was a poll
how did trump do in the debate 91
for trump nine
nine sisters look at these beautiful
sisters huh
they like they like trump but i like
them they even have a trump flag look at
that drum flight
[Applause]
that's beautiful it's so beautiful
and you know we're working very hard
with little sisters of the poor right
you know about that your friends that's
great that's great
it's great to have you thank you very
much joe biden is going to lock down
your state
wipe out your factory ship out your jobs
bring things to china whatever they can
punish your family
with a trillion think of this a trillion
dollars times four
four trillion dollar tax like we gave
you the biggest
tax reduction in the history of our
country
that's the good news the bad news is he
wants to give you the biggest tax
hike in the history of our country
he wants to eliminate private health
care we have 180 million people have
private health care they've
fought for it all their lives they have
great great health care he wants to
he wants to end it and it's not going to
happen we're not going to let it happen
and send your state into a very deep
recession not but see i think it's worse
i think it's depression i just hate to
use the d word
let me just tell you something how good
have i done in bringing
car companies here to michigan
you went 42 years without a car plant
you were losing all your plans
12 years ago i was named man of the year
of michigan can you believe long before
i thought about that
and i got up and i made a speech i said
you're losing all your carpets if
somebody gave me a list you lost
32 percent of your car business to
mexico and other places
and now we're bringing it all back you
have many many factories now
under construction expansions of
existing
you haven't had that ever and then biden
and remember this i only ran because of
biden and obama
if they did a good job i wouldn't have
run and i guess i wouldn't have
won either but i wouldn't have run they
did a lousy job i watched them now i'm
going to do this
i'm going to do that why the hell didn't
he do it
why didn't he do this sleepy joe and
that was when he was a little bit a
little bit better a little bit more
awake
he's going to do what he hasn't done in
47 years i'm going to do
that was so easy that debate because it
hit me i am going to do this and i just
kept saying
joe why didn't you do it you know and it
was three and a half years ago wasn't
like a long time it was three and a half
years ago biden has vowed
to abolish the entire u.s energy
industry right no fracking guy went for
a year and a half
no fracking no fracking no friend then
he goes to pennsylvania of course we're
going to frack
and and the press the fake news never
asks about it no energy
and you're gonna have gas prices this is
not great for selling your beautiful
cars
gas prices of six dollars and seven
dollars
right now it's nice to be under two
dollars isn't it you never thought you'd
see that
you never thought you'd see that biden's
running mate america's most
liberal senator she makes she makes
bernie look like a conservative
crazy bernie is like a conservative
compared to her
she even kamala
you have to pronounce it exactly right
otherwise she gets very upset
even though she can't pronounce it right
you saw that the other
i think that was actually that was on
the great laura ingram show actually i
watched that
and i do believe laura ingram is here
someplace
where is laura where is she
where is laura i can't recognize you
is that a mess no way are you wearing a
mask i've never
seen her in a mess look at you oh
she's being very politically correct
whoa i've never seen laura ingram she's
fantastic
ah yes i've never seen that before
but even sponsored the ruinous green new
deal how about that
knowing nothing about the environment
it'll cost a hundred trillion dollars
you know what a hundred trillion let me
put it this way you can take all the
countries in the world they can't afford
it
while i'm president america will proudly
remain
energy independent you know we're
independent now we don't need to be
going all over the world
we don't need to be going all over the
world biden will
eradicate the economy i will eradicate
the virus and make the economy better
than it's ever been that's where we were
now we're doing it again
[Music]
and let's face it he's shot do you agree
with that i can say i'm not a fan of his
never was
he was never known as the smart one in
the senate
he was a touchy-feely guy a little
personality he had a good person up
now the personality's gone and a lot of
other things are gone
he'll deliver poverty misery depression
ira will deliver jobs jobs jobs good
ones too
yesterday it was announced that last
quarter
when our economy you know when this was
announced it was a tremendous
announcement the problem with it was
that
we didn't get the kind of coverage that
we should have so in the history think
of it
in the history of our country gdp went
up
to 33.1 right in the history
and it was hardly mentioned it's amazing
a friend of mine very smart said to me
oh they won't talk about it
it's never been done before right they
won't talk about it because they don't
want you to win
because they're sick and they're corrupt
they don't want you to win
in the last five months we've created a
record 11.4 million
jobs the most jobs in the short period
of time
ever created and we also built the
greatest economy in history
and now we're doing it against all those
hats make america great again
again let's make america great again
again
but if biden wins the recovery will end
and a long economic nightmare just like
he said on the debate
you have a dark winter that was really
depressing it was even depressing even
though he did so badly in the debate i
was depressed because i said
that's such a depressing thing he said
i like the last statement though best
right wasn't that the best
we said that means you don't want oil
yes we are going to get off oil i said
this is like i felt like perry mason you
know it's always that last question
it's always the last question and i go
yes i'm guilty i'm guilty and then they
end the show and they go to a commercial
i said this is the biggest thing that
happened tonight
and even kristen walker who i thought
did a fair job okay i really did i
thought she did
a lot of people thought she was much
tougher than me but that we expect
okay but i mean and she looked at him
she goes
because she's on her side not his side
she's on a democrat radical left side
but she still did a relatively fair job
she said why did you say that
it's like why like why the hell did you
say that what the hell is wrong i'm
protecting you all night
and now you end the debate can we keep
it going for another 20 minutes no
i didn't want to do that joe biden spent
the last 47 years outsourcing your jobs
opening your borders once open borders
you don't have borders you don't have a
country
and sacrificing american blood and
treasure
in endless foreign wars we're bringing
them all back home
many of them all very very few
uh we're bringing them home gotta fight
the military
industrial complex eisenhower would talk
about it all the time
the military industrial complex they
don't like them coming home but they've
been brought home and
afghanistan 19 years i think is long
enough but we're serving as policemen
right
got the greatest soldiers in the world
we're serving as police we know they
have to have their own policemen
we have our own policemen they're the
greatest people we have right
the greatest he's a die-hard globalist
who cares nothing for the working people
he's never cared for the working people
china china has been ripping you off for
years now you know why he gets paid by
china
[Music]
he repeatedly tried to cut medicare and
social security over the years
biden was a cheerleader for nafta
sending your auto jobs
all over the place but in particular to
mexico mexico is a big auto monster
right now
usmca we did such a good job on that
he voted for china's entry into the
world trade organization one of the
worst things
that ever happened to our country the
best thing that ever happened to china
they were flatlined
and then they joined and they went like
a rocket ship thank you very much joe
great job you did joe
gutting your industries to finance
china's rise you see it all the empty
they still have empty buildings around
from
your state in particular half of all of
michigan auto manufacturing jobs
were limited think of it you lost 50
percent of your jobs because of these
guys
it's him and his group and then he says
oh we're going to do this
he'll come and say oh yes we did this we
he did nothing he destroyed your
industry
but i brought it back and you were doing
great and now
amazingly and i still haven't figured
this one auto productions
much higher than it was before the
pandemic could somebody in the auto
business please explain that one to me
because i'm taking full credit for it
but even i don't get that one i think
you're at 130
you're at 130 percent look at that sea
of people
i hope they can hear me
[Applause]
and housing starts and housing sales i
mean it's incredible but the auto
it's like in a number that nobody can
believe you're doing good
in other words you're all doing good
right it's a pandemic and you're doing
good
you got to get this governor you got to
get her to open
i am so tired of watching her husband go
sailing he wants to go sailing
he's saying darling open up this state i
want to go down but he was doing it
before unfortunately got caught
memory got caught his neighbors turned
him in can you believe it
at every turn i don't think she likes me
too much what do you think you think she
likes
i don't think she likes me too much and
i've done a great job for her
you know what on covid the china virus
i've done a phenomenal job for her
at every turn biden twisted the knife
into the back of michigan workers and
workers all over the country
in 2016 michigan voted to fire this
corrupt political establishment
and you elected an outsider as president
who is finally
putting america first if that's okay
and if i don't sound like a typical
washington politician it's because i'm
not a politician
and if i don't always play by the rules
of washington and the washington
establishment
it's because i was elected to fight for
you and i fight harder than any
president
has ever fought for the great people of
this country
and i'm not just running against sleepy
joe biden
i'm running against the left-wing media
the big tech
giants you see how crooked they are how
crooked are they
they made a mistake you know by not
putting it here you have the biggest
story there is right
corruption by joe biden forget about the
sun by joe biden but the sun the same
thing look
even if joe didn't get the 10 or the 50
that he was promised
listen to this the son walks and he had
nothing had no experience
he gets a job for 130 000 a month right
on barista and he gets a three million
dollar they say a three million dollar
upfront payment that sounds reasonable
but would anybody else take that job
a month and he knew nothing about energy
other than that it sounded fine
then he goes to china he picks up 1.5
billion dollars he gets fees on that
that's billions of dollars a year
and then they give him three and a half
million from moscow
the mayor of moscow's wife gives him
three and a half million you don't even
hear about this because they refuse
in fact they just turn the cameras off
they refuse
no
you see you can't have a scandal if they
don't report it
so the times and the washington post and
all of you know the fake news scene and
look they turned the cameras off
i do those
no it's a terrible thing they turned the
damn cameras off when they did that you
know what happened
they go we're here live at joe biden
he's doing everything there's nobody
there i'm looking
they're showing the sea of people 25 000
people
there's they're showing it's like a
scene and and the other one they're
looking and there's like
nobody there but they've gone to that
rally and fox has gone too i don't know
what the hell happened to fox huh
what happened to [ __ ] boy oh boy
well we still have a few great ones at
fox
we still have a few great ones
it's it's not like it used to be biden
is the case one of the biggest
differences between this campaign
and the campaign from four years ago
we're doing better now than we ever did
there's more enthusiasm the crowds the
crowds are much bigger
there's more enthusiasm but fox is a big
difference
somewhere along the line we lost fox and
that's okay
that's all right but that's a big
difference and the big text i'll tell
you the big texts are much worse you
know when i heard how bad they were
and i heard you can't win without them
they're so powerful and then we won i
said why are they powerful
now they've gone totally nuts okay mark
morgan one of our top people on the
border we've had a great border and he
was showing how great the wall is you
know we're almost finished with the wall
and how it's worked
and he said the success you probably
heard this
he said the tremendous success that
we've had and all he's doing is
he's not talking as a politician he's so
proud of the job
because people aren't getting into our
country murderers
and and rapists and all they're not
coming into our country anymore we're
working very closely with mexico
they have 27 000 troops on the border
and mark
morgan is explaining how great this wall
has been going to be finished
very soon it's much sooner or they're
going crazy because they never thought
we'd get it built right
that's why they don't talk about it
anymore they don't talk about the wall
they used to talk
about it now they don't talk about it
anymore but mark is talking about how
incredible the border security and they
took down his tweet
and they wanted to close them up all
he's doing is saying like we're doing a
good job
and he's not a politician he's saying
he's doing a good job they took down his
tweet
and they got the hell knocked out of him
and they put it back up i understand
but this is really bad and they don't do
that to liberals they don't do it to
liberals they don't ever do it they
don't touch them
it's very unfair and a lot of things are
happening biden is the candidate of
anarchists and writers and looters and
gun grabbers flag burners we ought to
put people in jail
for a year when they burn our flag
you know what the hell is that all about
i see them burning the flag
they ought to have you burn the american
flag you go to jail for one year
be amazing it's like we did we signed i
signed the law you knocked down a statue
or a monument
you go to jail for 10 years it's amazing
how that stopped
it's amazing how that stopped isn't it
but it's a lobbyist special interest i'm
the candidate of police
officers the middle class law-abiding
hard-working american patriots
and others i mean look i'm i think i'm
the candidate of everybody
one of them i think you got everybody
here i
know a couple of rich people get them
the hell out of here widow
[Music]
this election will decide whether we
restore the rule of a corrupt political
class
or whether we declare that in america we
are still governed we are the people we
govern we
govern we're the boss we're the people
[Applause]
my opponent supported the job-killing
trans-pacific partnership
would have destroyed your automobile
business and i ended it immediately in
fact
crooked hillary was in favor of it
their dues payers dues they want an
increase in dues they like their life
they like this
but you know the workers the auto
workers they support me like crazy
the teamsters you know you have this guy
hoffa
he calls up can you help him with a
trucking company some trucking company
big
beautiful company great people many many
thousands of employees
can you help us with that and i said
yeah i can probably do it i worked it
out so the people didn't lose their jobs
it kept the company going i was very
proud of it i thought it was great
then i see he's endorsing sleepy joe
biden biden can't get arrested okay
although actually that's turning out to
be true we can't get her
we got to think about that one he's
endorsing
joe biden but you know who's endorsing
me you know who likes me the teamsters
like me and everybody all of the workers
like that
maybe he won't run i think he's uh i
don't think he'd win anywhere every
round
biden even supported the outrageous fuel
economy standards you know that
that's where every little else they suck
every for half a glass of
gasoline which we have plenty of right
now we have so much we don't know what
the hell to do with it right
we had gasoline at one point selling for
so little
that if you took a barrel of gasoline
they gave you 36
with the barrel it only lasted for two
hours but i was thinking about leaving
government and going into that business
that's how that's how it is that's when
the pandemic came in and all of a sudden
people were
driving cars etc little things like that
but we have a lot of gasoline we have a
lot of
energy we have great energy and we
believe in all forms of energy
but when they want to turn off our great
factories by doing what they're doing
with people like aoc plus three telling
us how we're supposed to run our cars
arc plus three i don't think she ever
went i
did i don't she went to a college right
did she ever take an environmental
course
all of a sudden she's saying no more
cars no more planes no more flying
i reversed each and every one of those
disasters now biden wants to
re-institute he wants to
re-institute you know it took 20 21
years many highways and roadways simple
roadways would take 20 years to get
permits
i have it down to two years it's going
to be one year
and they may get rejected for
environmental reasons or safety reasons
but now we're building roads we're doing
things that we could never have done
before
a vote for biden is a vote to extinguish
demolish and wipe out michigan's auto
industry and many of your other
industries
many of your other industries a vote for
me is to keep
and create auto jobs and all sorts of
jobs
in michigan where they belong
i ended the nafta nightmare and replaced
it with the brand new usmca just kicked
in
just kicked it you know how i know it's
good because mexico
and canada aren't so happy they said
couldn't we keep
nafta i said no they said well we want
to we demand it i said
okay that's okay we're going to put a 25
tariff on every car you sent in
they said like i said wouldn't we like
to see the usmca done
no i said to them if you want to keep it
you can but i'm going to tear off the
cars that come into this country
so we made a great deal we made a deal
that's good for michigan
and good for everybody just kicked in
great for the farmers
it'll bring tens of thousands of new
jobs to michigan it'll bring hundreds of
thousands of new jobs to our country
and we won't be ripped off like we were
and it's a big disincentive
for a company to go and close up their
doors
and move to mexico move to canada now if
you do that there's a big price to pay
it's probably the primary reason i ran
if you want to know a lot of
i ran for a lot of reasons i ran because
the last administration was no good
period
i say it all the time joe i wouldn't
have run if it wasn't for you you guys
were so bad i ran
when gm went bankrupt biden and obama
threw the workers at delphi corporation
any delphi people here
[Music]
are you delphi where's delphi
oh i tell you i guarantee you they're
voting for trump
[Applause]
they threw these people under the bus
and days ago i signed an order to
restore the pensions and all of the
other things for workers not only delphi
in wisconsin ohio and michigan who are
treated very unfairly right
[Applause]
good i figured if we had none here i
would have just said the hell with it
you know
that's good all right you're going to be
taking care of you they were promised by
obama
they were promised by biden actually but
then biden realized he didn't understand
the deal he wasn't smart
he tried he tried joe tried he's having
a hard time
all right i'll tell you you know i see
these people in the level of
viciousness you see this character in 16
minutes screaming
savannah guthrie screaming like
screaming
all of them screaming and then i see
sleepy joe walk out
what flavor ice cream is it
he looks dead he actually had a hard
time with that question
i said they don't ask me questions like
that they don't do it
how about when they give them the
questions that's worse when he reads
them off
they give him a question this is the
people i deal with all the time they're
crazy maniacs
i deal with them all the time they ask
me things that are just terrible
and i've been doing this for a long time
they asked me very very dangerous
horrible questions
and with him it's like they give him the
questions in advance
and he puts it on a teleprompter just
like that they give him a question then
he goes
uh could you move that a little closer
and when i see that i said that means
that he has the questions
not since uh the hillary clinton scandal
when she got remembered
who who now that wonderful person that
did it donna brazile
is now working for fox so that was a
great hire
that was a great hire let's hire donna
brazile who got fired by cnn
and gets hired by fox what's that all
about do you think there's some changes
going on at fox i don't think so
oh i don't think so let's hire the
person that cheated with hillary clinton
joe biden is a corrupt politician the
biden family is looking more and more
like a crime family and they don't want
to it's called the laptop from hell
the laptop from hell they took
millions of dollars from the chinese
communists while vice president biden
shipped michigan jobs to china
how the hell can you have somebody
fighting for you against china and he's
getting money
him and his family are getting millions
and millions of dollars from china
and yesterday press reports i don't know
about this but press reports came out
yesterday said
the biden family is under fbi
investigation for a long time
for money laundering for
money laundering if biden wins china
which how do you have it
where they're getting millions and
millions of dollars from communist china
and then he's going to be your president
and he's going to make a deal like i do
i've taken
what i've done nobody has done what i've
done including to ucl where they were
dumping steel and i charged them a
tariff of 25
and our steel companies came back and
the 25
was just the beginning but our steel
companies come back i mean they all came
back
when we win michigan wins when we win
america wins and that's what i want
that's all i want
that's all i want i had a very good life
before this people think this is easy
you make a telephone call and these
really dishonest people they impeach you
on a perfect goal how are you doing
congratulations on your winner man
i never even spoke to i'd like to
congratulate you on you when he just
became the president of ukraine
let's impeach him for that these people
are sick but you know the republicans
stuck together
197 to nothing in congress
and 52 and a half 52 and a half
to a half does anybody know who the half
was yet
biden didn't know remember he said the
man
uh from utah what's his name i
he didn't know he didn't i forgot the
name of the man he's only worked with
him for about 35 years
something going on up there he won't be
there long he's not going to be there at
all
because our country will be destroyed
honestly we can't play games
we can't play games you can't put you
know
we have the potential we have more
potential as a country than we've ever
had
we can't have a guy like this in there
the guy doesn't have a clue
he doesn't and they'll say things that
are unbelievable he'll say things about
me
they do an ad about me that is so false
and you can't do a thing about it and we
put them in notice we said it was false
it was all false we put them a very
strong legal notice they keep it going
you know they figure what the hell the
thing's over within five days why should
we change it these are bad i'm telling
you those are bad people that's why i
say
i'm just going to tell you the truth
i'll tell you the truth but here's the
difference is this is the truth
he's shot okay he's shot
just like and it's not because of his
age because it's 78 or whatever it is
i know a lot of people that are 85 i
know a person
92 bernie marcus 92 home depot he's like
perfect i think he in fact i told him i
think he's sharper now than he was 25
years ago
no it's not the age you know they say
age it's not the age a lot of people
in their 80s even their 90s they show up
this guy is mentally shocked
one of the biggest issues for michigan
other than that let's keep it going
is this election is uh and you know what
one of you very big is the whole refugee
situation right i know it's a big deal
here
to protect our national security earlier
this week i
suspended the entry of refugees from
foreign nations
comprised by compromised by
terrorism so you saw what's going on in
france right
you saw that and they had another big
attack last night a really bad one
we are keeping if it's okay with you if
it's okay with the people of
the great people of michigan you got to
give me approval
we are keeping radical islamic
terrorists the hell out of our country
[Applause]
i remember i was in the campaign and i'm
running against this guy named ben
carson
and he was tough he was tough no he was
he was tough
and he made a statement somewhat similar
to that and everybody said oh he's going
to have to leave the campaign
i said no he's not his poll number's
just going way up i'll bet
next day what do they go up there like 7
eight nine points i said see
then i had to start really worrying
about this guy he went up
everyone said you had to leave right
kenny we he has to leave the campaign i
said no
no it's actually going to be good for
him we don't want to be used we don't
want to be taken
advantage of and i got passed i got
passed a ban
it's a ban on people coming in from
certain countries that are horrible
countries where they hate us and the
people hate us
right you know and one of the reasons
we're gonna go i'm going there later we
have a governor
and an attorney general we have 25 000
people
want to go in minnesota right one of the
reasons we're going to win and they want
us to have 250 people that's a slight
you know slight difference we have 25
000 people
but they have a rule you can't have more
than 250 people for a political event
so they're scamming us so you know what
that maybe will
give us the final victory we haven't won
minnesota since 1972.
okay 19 that's a long time which would
tell you the odds you know that's not
good odds
but we're very popular because i helped
with that disaster in minneapolis like
we got we got the guys in there and they
what did it take about uh 25 minutes it
was over
they should have called a long time
before they went through two weeks of
hell and
that's what we do the federal
governments are always prepared to come
in if you had problems the federal
government is always
prepared to come in we will extinguish
those problems
very very quickly but when you look and
we're always
and will always come in and some people
say it's not politically correct to say
that yeah it's politically correct
i thought it was a beautiful sight they
lined up
this is after a week and a half of
terror remember you had that idiot
anchor from cnn state
this has been a friendly protest and
over his shoulder
it looked like berlin in its worst day
during the war the worst day they ever
had
but no they told us we could only have
250 people so they thought i can't say
oh this is really great
trump book had said no i'm going to go
and i'll have 250 that's like the first
row
i'll have 250 people and they'll have a
lot of people outside but i don't want
them to stand outside it's colder there
than it is now
but it's very cold and very horrible
because
the president of the united states is
going to minnesota to talk to people
and they're suppressing it and they
think that's good but i don't that shows
weak leadership by the governor
and very unfair leadership by the
attorney general one thing i'll say
about that attorney general
i have to say this he was like the first
one he had a couple of people
he was sitting down being interviewed by
george stephanopoulos or somebody and he
said no but he was and he was like a
vice chairman of the democrat party and
you know who i'm talking about and he
said
trump is going to win this was like
right after i came down the escalator
with our future first lady right that
beautiful trip
the beautiful no and he said
trump is going to win no no no you
you're getting why why
no no trump is going to win so i
realized then
he's a very smart person
he turned out to be right about that one
didn't he nigel the great nigel
we're working to help
the chaldean christian community also by
the way
we're working to help them we're working
to help them
they've been they've been are you
chaldean
wow good oh good
all right now we're working to help
we're going to help
we're going to help you know you've only
been working on it for 25 years
just like i did with israel and so many
other things these guys they talk talk
talk nothing ever gets done
challenging what are you what are you
gonna show me there what do you you
opened your jacket look at this
oh now i like the chaldeans even more
[Applause]
oh that's good no they have great you
know what they have great support
they have great support they have great
support
good thank you very much
they do have great support but hey look
it's it's
a wildlife binder's pledge is staggering
700 this is with bernie sanders and
the manifesto we call it you know that's
the deal with bernie crazy bernie and
i mean he lost twice now guy's the
greatest loser i've ever seen
no he loses he doesn't even complain
about just goes back into congress
he votes holds up his hand radical
anything radical
a guy i've never seen a guy like that he
get treated very badly by the democrats
with hillary
then he runs again is bernie sanders
going to run again in four years does
anybody
i don't know he's all right i'll tell
you one thing he fights like hell right
he would have been who would have been
easier him or sleepy joe i don't know
no he has a smaller base but they have
energy joe has a bigger base but there
is zero energy right
now we have a really big base and we
have more energy than
a 700 increase in refugees from the most
dangerous
terror spots anywhere in the world
including syria
somalia where omar omar that's the other
reason i'm going to win
omar ilhan ilhan
omar she loves our country very much and
yemen
right now i'm going to help she's going
to help me when she's going to protest
when i go up there
and i'll say thank you very much every
time you protest has got to add about 25
of them the biden plan she's telling us
how to run our country
and she doesn't love our country that i
can tell you the biden plan
will turn michigan into a refugee camp
if you look at what they want to do
a seven this is agreed to with bernie
sanders in that group
a 700 increase
a lot of you people are saying no thank
you he has also vowed to terminate our
national security travel bans allowing
unlimited migration from deadly war
zones
and terrorist havens you're all sitting
here saying you know i think i'm
changing my vote
i think we'll go with trump that i even
have to do this
you know i i will say this and and it's
terrible but
you know before this covet there's about
24 names right i could
china plague china virus but we have
about 24 let's just go at the
china virus before the china virus came
we were going to have the easiest
campaign in history i was up so much
now i got to work right i have to work
and that's okay
actually i think people are it even more
they respect it even more
no but it has it's affected you know
it's affected polish you know politics
and leadership all over the world i mean
people that were very popular all of it
because it's a pale
but we've handled it well our people
have done an incredible job
are generals i mean look at the vaccines
look at hey excuse me look at me
i go in sister i wasn't feeling too good
and they gave me something called
regeneron the next morning sister i woke
up
and it was like god touched my shoulder
right i said mom let me adam
i said give me a trade deal for michigan
i want to go and
renegotiate a trade deal now what
they've done is incredible in a
short period of time six months i mean
they never even heard of this drug
and now eli lilly's also doing something
similar we have things coming out that
are amazing and
even the times row today people are
getting better people are getting better
because of what's happening
and for the times to write that that's a
very very hard thing for them to write
you would have thought they would have
waited a few days actually
let's wait let's put out that story on
the fourth of november
and you know that's everything's covered
covert covered you know that you turn
into the news cove at cove at cove at
cove at covent
and uh you know cases are up why a case
is up because we test more than anybody
in
history i mean we test we have tests on
top of tests we'd like another test
we've got 19 different verbs
and we test much more than india they
have 1.5 billion people
many countries don't test at all many
countries don't test at all
but we test more but deaths are way down
and where people are getting better but
i'm an example of it
my wife is an example of it first lady
and baron trump young you know very
young 14
he's my very tall 14 year old boy
strong he's he's a tall guy
but he's a strong guy and you know he
tested part the doctor said
sir baron has tested positive the
doctors here sean
great doctor said he's tested positive i
said
positive for what he said kovit
i said oh that's terrible he said no
he'll be okay
like 15 minutes later how's baron doing
doc oh it's okay he's fine now
no they have strong immune system now
they'll say he exaggerated the tower
they're so sick
you know what i said you know i got
myself into trouble with that also a
great gentleman from england
i said that refugees are coming in and
they promise him more than they give our
citizens
they said we're going to give you health
care we're going to give you a free
education
and every refugee that comes in will get
a free rolls royce
and cnn went crazy they said
president trump lied they're not getting
a rolls-royce you know
they took it very seriously you can't be
sarcastic you can't have a little bit of
fun
because if you do you look very bad no
they said
it's not true about the rolls-royce but
800 at 800 000 a pop i would say
probably not
they took it cnn took that very
seriously joe biden's plan will delay
the vaccine postpone therapies
crash the economy and shut down our
entire country
under the biden lockdown countless
americans will die from
suicide drug overdose deferred medical
care
so many things happen abuse i mean
what's happening
there will be no school no graduations
no weddings no thanksgivings no
christmas
no fourth of july
there'll be no nothing there'll be no
future other than that it's quite a good
plan i think
biden doesn't have a clue look the cure
cannot be worse than the problem itself
always remember
biden wants to keep everyone locked up
even young americans who are at
extremely low risk from the virus
he wants to steal the dreams and the
futures of our
youngest citizens and you know when a
child
loses a year of his life because he's
locked in
and one thing we have found you know
there a lot of telehealth has been great
and a lot of
but when you're looking at a laptop it's
not nearly as good as sitting in a
classroom that has been
that has been determined it's not good
it's not the same
and we're keeping these kids away from
school and that's something
i mean it's great in some instances and
telehealth is one of them
but when it comes to school we've
learned very strongly it's not the same
which is why i'm going to win we're
going to win with a record number i
think there's a
vote out there that is incredible let me
ask you a question
who has voted by ballard or who has
voted so far
okay who is going to vote on tuesday
[Applause]
it's a funny thing you know we tell our
people go out and vote
we're not big into the ballot world we
sort of don't like it okay
you know because too many tricks get
played like they find ballot trump
allison a waste paper basket
they find them in dumpsters they found
some in the river is that not
lovely look all those ballots oh they
happen to be trump ballots no they're
finding them all over the place
500 incorrect applications go get sent
to virginia
the beauty was they sent many ballots to
a certain state
they were only defective in one way they
didn't have the name trump on it in
other words
if you wanted to vote for trump what do
you do i guess you're supposed to write
it out
then they'll say you can't do that no
it's a
crooked deal it's a crooked deal it's a
very sad thing
we like going to vote and the other
thing funny they don't want to vote i
could say go to vote on saturday or
sunday or monday
they really want to vote on election day
i like it and we are going to have a red
wave the likes of which has never been
seen
and let me give the democrats the bad
news
their vote is under what they thought
they needed
thank you but their votes are under you
know they're not performing like they
should
they'll probably drop some of the
ballots and sign them real quick i could
just see the governor of nevada upstairs
never do this but
get me some ballots we'll lose in here
being
because you know they don't want to have
any signature verification in nevada
they don't want the governor he was a
political guy if he ran the political
club so you know
he's a beauty so they don't want to have
any verification of a signature
so if they lose it they'll say get me
some balance real quick i'll sign them
myself
now i went to vote i voted and i went
into a place
in palm beach and i said boy this is so
the woman said
sir mayor please see your identification
i said
that's true but i wanted that you know i
mean i i wanted
so i took out a passport sir do you have
any other form of identification
i said are you serious i said no but i
did i gave her something else
and i sat and i filled out the form i
mean it was there was no way you could
cheat there was no way i mean it was
really good it was really professional
and other people they come in
it was so nice and we should have voter
id by the way voter id
the whole country and thanks to our
relentless efforts only three percent
of er visits nationwide right
are related to the virus so three
percent of hospital
rooms emergency rooms three percent are
related right now exactly just came out
last night three percent to the virus
uh a lot of people you know you read
about cases but now they're young people
they're college students they're younger
than college students
but they love the word case because
cases cases have gone
up they don't say that it's a you know
14 year old kid or that it's a
20 year old student or i mean you go
under 70
and you go under certain ages and it's
99.9
to just you know it's a whole different
thing but they don't like to talk
but i see it's always cases are up and
people go crazy you know
now it's uh you live with it and you
have
and you know what to do we understand it
now you gotta understand it
but we're making that beautiful turn and
the vaccines have come and due to our
groundbreaking therapies
the fatality rate is down 85
think of that and our excess mortality
rate
is 42 lower than europe they kept saying
germany
germany germany first of all they have
different ways of counting
you know in germany if you have a bad
heart and you're ready to die
or if you have cancer and you're going
to be dying soon and you catch covet
that happens
we mark it down to covet you know our
doctors get more money if somebody dies
from kelvin you know that right
i mean our doctors are very smart people
so what they do is they say i'm sorry
but you know
everybody dies of coffee but in germany
and other places
if you have a heart attack or if you
have cancer you're terminally ill you
catch cover they say you died of cancer
you died of heart attack with us when in
doubt
choose covet that's true no it's true
now they'll say oh it's terrible what he
said but that's true
it's like two thousand dollars more so
get more money
this could only happen to us where cases
are now surging and
despite if you look at europe they're
surging despite these draconian
lockdowns
they have it locked down and they're
surging so
what happens is you get it you're gonna
get if you get it
stay away if you get it you're gonna get
better and then you're gonna be immune
and it's a whole thing and it goes away
but the vaccines will have but don't
take my word for it because
we have a video and i want to just show
you a little video we only do this to
people we really like because this thing
costs a lot of money
so we have a very little and very quick
video but it's very descriptive
and it talks a little bit about sleepy
joe okay
the fact is every time i've uh called
the president he's quickly gotten on the
line
when we asked to get support for that
mercy ship in southern california he was
able to direct that
in real time what the federal government
did
working with states was a phenomenal
accomplishment
we got 2 000 of these vehicle field
medical sites that are up almost all
operational now in the state
uh because of his support those are the
facts uh his team
has been on it i know a team when
they're on it
and i know a team when they're not on it
his team is on it they've been
responsive
late at night early in the morning we
are working very well with fema region 2
with the army corps of engineers
building four field hospitals
that was a decision the president
himself took and i'm grateful for it
these were just extraordinary efforts
and acts of mobilization and
the federal government stepped up we
needed help and they were there
he said everything that i could have
hoped
for and we had a very long conversation
and every single thing he said they
followed through
we've got to have double the number of
ventilators that we requested for that
area of the state and in fact
we got them in frankly short order have
we lost anyone
because we didn't have a bed or we
didn't have a ventilator
or we didn't have health care staff
no the president was extending support
for new swabs
so conversation commitment
promise made promise kept
[Music]
my problem is i voted for now i'm
supporting nafta
because i think it is a positive thing
to do and i do not pretend to be an
expert on
international trade matters trade
agreements like nafta and permanent
normal trade relations with china which
forced american workers
to compete against people making pennies
an
hour has resulted in the loss of 160 000
jobs the president is absolutely right
when he says that china has been
cheating for 25 years
and that bill clinton didn't do enough
about it george w bush didn't do enough
about it barack obama didn't do enough
about it
rising china is an incredibly positive
development
for not only china but the united states
and the rest of the world
rising china is a positive positive
development
it is in our self-interest that china
continue to prosper
we want to see china rise china is a
great nation
and we should hope for the continued
expansion china is not our enemy
we talk about china this is our
competitor
we should be helping the idea that china
is going to be our lunch
is bizarre
they're not bad folks folks china's not
a problem
allowing china into the world trade
organization which he supported
extending most favored nation status to
china which you supported
that those steps allowed china to take
advantage of the united states
by using our own open
trade deals against us do you think in
retrospect that you were naive about
china
but doesn't he deserve some credit for
that it's better the us mta is better
than nafta
it is better than nafta now to be fair
maybe biden's not telling us
because he's forgotten his own plans
watch biden's staff quickly swoop in to
shuffle him along during a quickie
escape the basement trip to pennsylvania
here's the deal one of the things that
that is important
is that
keep in mind although they're going to
vote on
barracks i think
that was terrifying what kind of country
we're going to be
four more years of george georgia
he uh is going to find ourselves in a
position where
if uh trump gets elected uh we're going
to be uh we're gonna be in a different
world
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't know i don't know
i don't know what to tell you
thank you very much thank you very much
but that says it all that's easier than
talking for a half hour it says it all
has no clue where he is we're joined by
some incredible people and warriors ben
carson and his
incredible wife candy candy carson thank
you very much
thank you ben great job he does what a
great man
congressional candidates i hear he's hot
i hear he's doing great
paul young paul
that's great paul i hear it's going good
you're winning huh i'm hearing good
things
you're gonna win and eric isaki
eric thank you eric
thank you very much good good luck eric
heard you doing
really we need these two guys please
vote for
and michigan gop chair laura cox
thank you are we winning laura
i see we're up we're just up in the poll
by three points
good so carry it in i mean three points
how the hell you beat this guy by three
points is that a win
i don't know hey if it's one vote we'll
take it right
we gotta win we gotta win michigan is
very important
michigan it's very important for
michigan that we win
for 47 years joe biden betrayed the
african-american community
biden devastated black families with his
disastrous
1994 crime bill that came up very much
in the debate
he called young black men super
predators and he did it all the time
i gave former prisoners a second chance
by signing our landmark
criminal justice reform that biden
couldn't do and obama couldn't do
joe biden flooded black neighborhoods
with illegal foreign labor
and i'm providing black neighborhoods
with billions of dollars
thanks with our opportunity zones which
have turned out to be incredible
tim scott opportunity zones have been
incredible what they've done for
communities and for hispanic black
workers under our platinum plan we'll
create three million new jobs for black
americans restore safety to every
neighborhood
and we'll deliver school choice to every
parent in america
right good
and in conclusion i just want to say
it's been
an honor to be with you this is
incredible it's cold out here
it's cold i'd say it's a little cold
but over the years and over the next
four years
we will make america into the
manufacturing superpower of the world
and we will end the reliance on china
once and for all that's already started
we will hire more police increased
penalties for assaults
on law enforcement and we will ban
deadly sanctuary cities
we will end the big tech monopoly and
restore freedom of speech
we will defend religious liberty the
right to life
and the right to keep and bear arms
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military might
and we will ensure peace through
strength
we will end surprise medical billing
require
price transparency lower drug prices
even more
we have done something nobody's done 52
years
last year drug prices went down but now
they're going to go down
at a very high rate because we're doing
favored nations
the drug companies don't like me too
much i will tell you
we will protect social security and
medicare
and we will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions
america will land the first woman on the
moon in the united states will be the
first nation
to land an astronaut on mars we will
stop
the radical indoctrination of our
students
and restore patriotic education
to our schools we will teach our
children to love our country
honor our history and always respect
our great american flag
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national motto
in god we trust
[Applause]
for years you had a president who
apologized for america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america
and standing up for the great people of
michigan
see now a lot of times by edward said
standing up for the great people of ohio
ohio no it's michigan that's happened
seven times
can't do that you can't let that happen
you can't let that happen
we did not come this far and fight this
hard only to surrender our country back
to the washington swamp
so get your friends get your family get
your neighbors
and get out to vote get out to vote
got to do it got a big day tuesday
don't even do it on monday my people
said i'll let them go monday sunday
don't worry about just do it like you
like to do it
just do it tuesday's good
on november 3rd we must finish the job
and drain the swamp once and for all
nobody ever said
it was going to be that deep nobody ever
said it was going to be that deep and
that vicious but we're knocking the hell
out of them they don't know what the
hell is going on
it's been tough for them to they never
had a thing like this
from midland to mackinac from lansing to
grand rapids
and from battle creek to right here in
waterford township
nice
we inherit the legacy of michigan
patriots who gave their blood sweat and
tears for this beloved nation
this is the state where henry ford
invented the assembly line think of that
[Applause]
it's the place where general motors
chrysler and kellogg
revolutionized entire industries what a
state
michigan gave us motown the mustang
and the unrivaled might of the american
midwest
we made america into the single greatest
nation in the history of the world
and the best is yet to come
[Applause]
proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country we are returning power to you
the american people
that's what i said i was going to do
with your help
your devotion your drive we are going to
keep on working
we are going to keep on fighting and we
are going to keep on
winning winning winning
we are one movement one people one
family
and one glorious nation under god and
together
with the incredible people of michigan
we have made america powerful again
we have made america wealthy again
we have made america strong again
we have made america proud again
we have made america safe again
and we will make america
great again thank you michigan go out
and vote
[Music]
[Music]
cause you're in a new town there's no
need to
be unhappy
[Music]
and i'm sure you will find many ways
[Music]
it's fun to stay at the mccoy
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
what do you
but you've got to know this
one thing no man does it all by
put your himself on the shelf and just
go down
to the ymca i'm sure
[Music]
today
[Music]
it's hard
[Music]
you can do whatever you'll
[Music]
[Music]
ymca they can't stop you
back on your way
it's fun to stay at the mca
it's fun
[Music]
pick yourself off the ground
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ymca
[Music]
[Music]
why
[Music]
[Music]
michigan
me
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh
[Music]
jesus
[Music]
she's not